[Music]
that conversation we had about grabbing
that house up in Napa how what else how
much the family I want our kids to be
able to play outside
this is that sixty seven forty one so
pretty I'm Charlie Peck Scott our
welcome to Fox Club my great-great
grandfather built this house is the only
house I ever lived in I put my soul into
it
Fox pub is your style what's it good
care of her so bathroom I feel bad for
Charlie cook good for us you're not
gonna believe this charlie is outside
cutting the grass what did you just get
this out of the garage that's why I keep
it that she'd be gone by now
that's hard too hard say goodbye
keep hearing this creaking sound mani is
old house you just bought the pack up
right yeah Charlie's quite a guy just
don't look too close under the mask is
why I've died in that house mrs. Charlie
mr. Charlie shotgun in her mouth
at least that's how Charlie explained it
the man acts like the house still
belongs to any he's lonely
okay it's not your house
Sky's dangerous
I see the way that he looks at you now
charlie is after me stay away from my
wife if you lost everything that was
important then you will you just go for
it
white dog okay we're not dying
everything I do I do for us
[Music]
you